maîtres du rire et de la joie dans ce
monde
et rien à voir avec les films de super
héros habituels où ça explose dans tous
les sens où tout le monde est super
génial là c'est plutôt le côté
psychologique qui change pas mal des
films habituel qui ont pas vraiment de
fond et c'est très intéressant
les images étaient très symétrique du
coup ça nous mettait à l'aise et du coup
c'est vraiment un contraste avec le jeu
d'acteur qui était très perturbant très
oppressant même le côté psychologique
est vraiment très frappant du personnage
et l'histoire et on comprend mieux aussi
les origines de ce personnage et on
comprend mieux aussi les origines de
batman les images le jeu d'acteur
incroyable mal à l'aise avec le corps
qu'il a faim c'est vraiment incroyable
ce que ce qu'il a réussi à faire c'est
la manière dont ces tournées la manière
dont ces films est vraiment concentré
sur le personnage
sa famille s'est enfin sa maman et ses
terrains sauf que ça change un peu la
façon dont on peut voir le joker russie
quoi c'était vraiment profond profond de
l'homme en noir
et ça m'a touché dans un niveu que c'est
la première fois que j'ai regardé un
film ça m'a donné ce sentiment avant je
me disais que ma vie était une tragédie
je m'en rends compte
[Musique]
c'est une prime et d